well good evening everybody welcome to
the march meeting of the accounts and
audit committee
uh the first item agenda is attendances
i think we're all
present apart from councillor evans will
join the meeting later
later on i've not had any apologies
there's anybody any apologies to report
no all right item two is declarations of
interest
there are any no
out of three questions from members of
the public have there been any uh
joe no chair not received any for this
meeting no i've not had yet
thanks very much thank you item for the
minutes of the last meeting
can we agree there's a correct record
yeah
thanks very much newton seconded joe
item five is the presentation on the
star
procurement update that's from lorraine
cox we're just saying lorraine it's over
a year since you
were with us before before the dreaded
lockdown so if you'd like to start i
think you're going to
share your slides aren't you by the
miracle of zoom technology
okay where you going lorraine
you need to a mute sorry
very well
let me just um bring this up as a
slideshow
and then hopefully nice and big on the
screen
can we see that not yet no
have you pressed the green button and
everything
it worked before didn't it
that's it yeah right fantastic lovely
thank you chair
um yes good evening everybody um i'm
lorraine cox i'm the director of star
procurement um
and i i i think it is correct i think it
was certainly over a year ago when i
last attended this um committee at
trafford
and um i think the intention was that i
was going to give you a six monthly
update but
all the reasons we know um national and
international
um issues you know globally really in
terms of covered
have overtaken us so thank you for the
opportunity this evening
and i will be talking probably about
some data and from from a good while ago
but it's still very relevant and it will
bring you up to speed with
where we are in terms of star and
progression
um bear with me
okay so just just conscious that there
may be some members here
and this evening that perhaps haven't
met me before or indeed and heard me
speak so
i just want to just remind members if i
may just who who star procurement is um
we are trafford council first of all um
i sit on your payroll i am an employee
of trafford council you host
star and star is actually um what we
call a shared
service in the public sector and we
actually work for
stockport trafford rochdale and
thameside councils
and we also work for um two new members
to the group which is um trafford
clinical commissioning group
and tame side and glossar clinical
commissioning group so we actually work
for six organizations now
to deliver procurement
in terms of business objectives we've
recently in in january launched the new
business plan for star
and it was due to go out last year but
again for obvious reasons and it was
delayed um but what we've done is we've
just refocused
um what our objectives are and um
we've kept the same vision which is
leading transformation through
procurement and cooperation
and what we've done is just refined our
five objectives slightly and just using
the five c's again
which are communities commerciality
collaboration
confidence and be courageous so we've
just sharpened i suppose the emphasis of
what star is about
um in order that we've got quite a
structured way of
moving star forward as a business unit
for yourselves
and indeed the other five partners and
if you haven't seen the business plan
and i can certainly get that circulated
round and but it is on our website and
as i say has been launched for a couple
of months now
under the business plan we talk about
enablers and forgive me i'm just going
to look at this screen here i've not got
my glasses on um our enablers are around
leadership and governance and for me
and the reason star works is that we
have a very strong
leadership team under my commands but
also we have
very strong leadership and governance
from the representative councils
and both in terms of officers that sit
on a board and we also have the joint
committee which those of you will know
councillor ross represents trafford
and it has a delegated role from your
exec
and that's what makes the unit work very
effectively because we're very
represented and it's a very equal
partnership
we have communications and engagement as
an enabler because clearly it's very
important to tell
everybody what we do why we do it how we
do it we're very accountable in terms of
performance management through the board
and joint committee and we have some
quite rigorous performance management
targets
set within the year we use technology
and data and that's been challenging to
all of us
um i'm going to say of a certain age
because i am of a certain age over the
last
year in terms of using platforms like
zoom but what we've done is we've worked
really hard to look at how we use
data to enable technology and data to
actually
monitor and measure what we do and
report on it using systems like tableau
and we're just using a new system
now called intend which is around
contract management so we've really
progressed i would say
technology logically if i can say it and
i'm
the fourth enabler which i think is
really really important and particularly
to trafford because you are our host
you are our employer is it's about
talent management and it's how we
um secure retain and grow
um a highly effective workforce and i
think
quite confidently i can say in my just
over four years four and a half years of
being
and the director of staff that we have a
massive retention
within the workforce and we have very
little people leaving
and the odd one or two that do tend to
go off for quite progressive roles so
we feel we invest a lot and we do grow
our own and make sure that that
workforce is this
um adequate and professional as it can
be
um moving on just to some achievements
apologies that if this is 1920 and we're
nearly at the end of 2021
um but um we are where we are um
what we did achieve in 1920 was um
firstly exceeding all targets that were
set by the joint committee and i'm just
going to
put a few numbers on that side um in
terms of savings within 1920 we saved
over seven million pounds of cashable
savings
just for the four councils within the
star family
and which year on year that savings
target increases
and year on year we continually deliver
and exceed
that target and which which is really
really
a good success story um social value i
think we talked about this or presented
on this last time and we talked about
um tom's measures and i think that was
circulated around to you all to have a
look at
and within 1920 and our very first year
of launching
the approach using the social valley
portal what we did see was
um we actually secure 25
of added value so what that really means
is for every pound
that we spent as a collective group of
four councils in particular
above a 25 000 pound contract value
and because that's the threshold that we
use but for every pound that we spent we
committed contractually
we basically got 25 pence back return
from those contractors that won those
contracts which actually equated to
over 31 million pounds of additionality
and on top of the contract that we've
specified
and those contractors are delivering to
now when i talked to you
over a year ago nationally and the view
was that we should be aspiring by 2025
to be hitting the target of 25 percent
added value
and we actually achieved that in in year
one of 1920.
now forever the optimist we're coming to
the end of march now and i'm hoping
that we at least match that this year
during you know quite challenging year
for
all of us but actually we're hoping that
we match that 25
if not actually exceed it so i think the
trajectory that we've taken social value
is absolutely robust it's nationally
recognized
we've actually won an award recently for
embedding social value into procurement
so we're absolutely trailblazing them at
the forefront of success
um i think another figure i just want to
point out there chair on that slide is
the 57
lower down and what that represents is
of the contracts that went through the
social value portal in 1920
57 of those contracts so that's not
value that's the actual number of
contracts
actually got awarded to greater
manchester businesses
um again it's another target that joint
committee set me
annually to make sure that we're pushing
hard on actually making sure we spend
our not just traffic pound but our star
pound within
greater manchester across the four
boroughs and the wider region
so i think there's some really good
achievements there that i'm sure you
will agree
with um spend and compliance
this is an interesting one and what i've
done is i've
actually just put some color codes on
the slides just to help me talk you
through it but it would just work from
the right to the left
and what you have seen before on the set
of slides from a year ago was i actually
reported on this 1718
set of figures and i've reported on the
1819
um set of figures so the new data today
which you haven't seen before is the bit
that's blocked in yellow on on the 1920
column
so basically what this is telling you is
that um if we look at the the red
figures first of all
what it's telling you is since 1718
so in the last three financial years
we've actually supported trafford
council
with local spend initiatives and buy
local and making sure that procurement
is
continuing to to improve that agenda for
you
but we've actually moved you from 17 of
your
what we call contracted third party
spend
from from 17 in 1718 and right
up to 1920 that sits consistently now at
49
which is is more or less in line with
the other star partners now we've
actually managed to move
all of them um quite quite radically
forwards with a number of initiatives
i think what's interesting is and when
you look at the actual monetary figures
as well
um every year you spend slightly
different amounts of money because um
you know you have different contracts
that expire you have new projects that
come on so the actual
what we call influential sum of money
the controllable elements that we can
control and influence and procurement
does vary
so you have to be careful i suppose
making sure that it is apples and apples
so to speak as you compare one year to
the next
but i think the important thing is is
your monetary value has increased to
97 92.7 million
that's actually been spent locally
within the borough
in 1920 and as i say that that
percentage is 49 which is consistent so
that's really really good news
moving into the green data the green
data into two columns um
you can see that we've actually retained
more of the spend within
greater manchester because not only do i
look at where does trafford's money go
in terms of in trafford and then say
well if it didn't land in traffic did it
land within greater manchester
and the green figures will show that the
journey from 1718 has gone from 39
million
and 37 million and then actually we've
seen that increase to 51 million so
basically what that's showing is
if we haven't landed that contract
within a trafford
business it's gone to a greater
manchester business equating to 51
million pounds and then the third set of
data on there which i've marked
in purple just hopefully for ease is
obviously i want to increase more
traffic spend more gm
spend so the net impact of that is that
we start to reduce and see a reduction
in what you spend
nationally and the figures concur there
because we've gone from 54
of national spend from 1718 to the
reporting data in 1920
right down to 24 so you can see how that
money
over the three years is is quite
radically
i would say rather than slowly but quite
radically moving in the right direction
in terms of
more local spending trafford more
regional spend within greater manchester
and less going nationally
move on to the next slide um
something we worked on um shortly after
we went exactly a year today and into
lockdown was
we said what can we do to help
businesses and because
procurement has it has a key function
here in terms of making sure we still
buy things
and making sure councils still spend
their moneys okay some of it's been
diverted
and used for other priorities but what
we've still tried to do is to say how
can we help
our business cohorts within greater
manchester
so we've got a 10-point plan that we
launched i think in the round about
april may last year which basically was
a commitment from my team
to work with your teams you finance
teams your commissioners to say
what can we do to make sure we give
businesses the very best chance
so i'll pick a couple of those out and
we did a meet the buyer event
in um trafford actually it was hosted by
trafford obviously it was in
a virtual environment but we had over
600 businesses
and register and attend that meet to buy
a week and we actually run it in
november and we run it
um over a five day period rather than
the usual one day where we're all in
and what would have been the um qriket
place across the road from the town hall
so um we
carried on doing as much business as
usual as we could in order to make sure
that businesses are still seeing those
opportunities
and is still able to bid intended for
work um
another one is we looked at social value
in contrast
number eight and we gave businesses the
opportunity to say
can you still deliver your social value
because clearly we've secured that 31
million pounds of added value
most of them said yes we can some said
no we can't
for other pressures but can we offer you
something different and what we found
we actually got greater offer from the
business communities
and what they did was they looked at
doing more things and more activities
that would actually enable um
covered related issues and and helping
things with it within the region
um another one to share with you
was um market engagement again what we
looked at was actually how
we engage with the market earlier to
give them basically the heads up
of what was actually going to be
procured in order that they could
prepare
for their submissions to give them
enough lead time because they had
greater priorities than
just winning contracts or bidding for
the contracts to actually survive
through
through this awful 12 months so what we
did was look at how we can lengthen the
procurement process to give particularly
the small and medium enterprises
the opportunity to still bid and what we
did on the backdrop of all of this was
we monitored
um activity from smes from vcscs
voluntary sector small and medium
enterprise sector
to actually check that they're still
participating in tender exercises and
winning tender exercises i'm really
optimistic
that i'm hoping we're going to see the
fruits of our labor really after the
12-month
period at the end of march that we've
actually got a success story
that we've had some good contracts one
locally
within trafford and also within greater
manchester
um that ten point plan was actually
nominated for three national awards we
did get shortlisted but unfortunately we
didn't win but
it's certainly been recognized by the
local government association and other
organizations as a really good way to
support
businesses through the last 12 months
so what did we deliver and what are we
doing next
um when i looked at my slides from over
a year ago
and there were things in there that we
were talking about i i talked to you
about social value performance and
we were certainly on the journey and
with social value and using this new way
of working um
and hopefully with the numbers i've just
shared in terms of 31 million and the 57
of contracts being awarded in greater
manchester in that first year
i think you can see that you know what
what i said we did in terms of making
that social value approach work
and i've talked about the ten point plan
um i've obviously told you about the new
business plan which was eventually
launched in january of this year
um meet the viruses i've already
mentioned was very successful
and and we've had some really good
feedback from businesses in terms of how
that was delivered
using the virtual methods making sure
that everything where it could be was
videoed
so businesses can re-watch any of those
workshops and training sessions
not at the leisure because they don't
have leisure these people who are
working
very very hard running small businesses
but they could watch things that
when they have time because people don't
always operate
nine to five nice week um operations so
that that was really successful this
year and i suspect as we move forward
since
next year we will probably look at
whether we can do a bit of both in terms
of virtual
and face-to-face um i've mentioned that
we won an award in um
social hollywood's everybody's business
for embedding social value
um which was absolutely you know super
revenues for the team
and indeed the wider council partners
because we're part of
a wider team in the council in terms of
the commissioners the buyers the budget
holders
um embedding social value isn't
performance responsibility is actually
everybody's responsibility so that
award is very much for all of us
what's next a couple of pieces of work
we're developing at the moment is one to
look at the social value toms the
measures now
where we historically issued a big long
list to businesses and said
tender for this contract tell us what
social value you want to offer
what we're trying to do now is reverse
that to actually link that with your
corporate priorities
in order that we ask businesses for what
we want because what's important to me
to deliver for members is to making sure
that any social value that's offered
is actually benefiting socially
environmentally
and economically to the people on the
streets in trafford
and indeed across greater manchester as
well so we're trying to really switch
that round now
to make sure that the social value that
comes from contracting from procurement
is actually relevant to help you deliver
your corporate priorities
and then the last one to reference is um
we've started a piece of work with
offices at the moment um
looking at how we develop um trafford as
a social value
organization and i know particularly the
leader is very keen
to be you know the first in the country
and what this basically means is looking
at how social value
can reach out beyond procurement to be
in planning processes decision making
processes
and rent awards anything that you do
where a decision is made
how can social value and considerations
be given
in order that you can become a social
value organization that basically walks
and talks
social value through all parts of your
business and there's the same
just developing um this concept with
offices at present and i know it will be
fun to exec
in a think jew and i think
i think my last slide is question so i'm
more than happy to take questions
thanks very much lorraine could he kill
your uh screen sharing that i can see he
wants to put the hand up
for questions
all right thanks very much okay i can
see everybody
if you either use the reactions button
at the bottom and just wave your hand
probably
if you want to ask a question
can i start off with a simple question
really
when you say you're making a saving of
10 percent whatever
how do how do you measure that is there
a sort of haggling process to
does a supplier say this is going to
cost you a hundred pounds and you say oh
no i don't think so you get it down to
90 pounds
is that the way it works in looking at
private sector absolutely yes
you go into that hard nose negotiation
obviously for procurement and
the invigorous transparent um as we are
and to make sure that everything is is
compliant
and working within the rules you know
nationally and regionally
what we do is we look at quality price
and social value and we
weight those three elements within the
tender process so when a bidder actually
puts a submission in
they will know how many points in simple
language they will get
um if the price is sharp
if their quality is sharper meets the
specification and now
third element is social value so um we
do use something called baffle best and
final offer so
with certainly the contracts of sort of
up to about 180
000 pounds we will baffle um some of the
work to actually push that
sharpening of the pencil so to speak a
little bit further so
um the saving comes from um bidders
bidding but we balance that with quality
because you want to make sure that you
know
you've got contrast that can actually do
what you need them to do but
now we have an element of social value
within that waiting too
thanks councillor uh cookies i think was
first
yeah thanks um that's some really
impressive um
information on there the um um
the move from 17 to 49 percent of local
spend in such a short time was
is um really remarkable um
i i wanted to ask about um
then what your social impact involves i
think you
talked a bit about this perhaps the last
time you were here um
particularly interested uh in the the
climate
elements really i suppose um and
obviously the council has now written a
carbon neutrality action plan i was
wondering if that's something that has
come to you
and if your team are working on that and
there's
there's obvious elements and what you
talked about things like
trainees and apprenticeships um
well nearly everything that you've
talked about i suppose um
could be considered in a um from climate
point of view so i'm just wondering what
you're doing about that
and yeah thank you thank you
really good question actually and very
relevant for all the reasons we know
um social value is is made up of
environmental
economic and social elements so that the
tom's
measures um break down subcategories
under those three headings
um because we've offered um you know the
sort of shopping list
the cherry pick list for the businesses
to to choose and beard
we tend to get what they want to give us
and we tend to get the same things over
and over which is around apprenticeships
which is great
and worthless nurse looking at um
spending their supply chain within the
borough that sort of thing
and don't get me wrong that 31 million
is wonderful and we wouldn't
not want it but what we're looking at
now is firstly bespoking to your
corporate priorities
um to make it more real for trafford and
we'll do the same for the other
organizations
but the second point of your question
around climate for me
for the fact that we know you've got
your action plan now
we've also got the 2038 commitment
across greater manchester
and to be carbon neutral so there's a
lot of factors
regionally um as well as the trafford
and the other councils and nationally
and obviously globally as well because
we look at the the international
um um goals as well in terms of the 17
factors
so we have to work globally right down
to the doorstep of trafford to say what
is important
so what we're working on at the moment
is to say can we actually consider
waiting firstly waiting those um
measures so we can say to businesses
if you offer um something that will help
our carbon reduce
you will get more points in very simple
language here
and the other thing we could do and we
could consider which i know manchester
city council have just moved towards
is actually putting a percentage
weighting
purely for um carbon reduction so
there's two schools of thought there
and i'm actually with the joint
committee of star tomorrow and this will
be one area that we will be discussing
because
it's absolutely the forefront of
everybody's business and i think we need
to work harder and quicker
for the reasons we know so it's it's
nationally important departments
globally important but actually
we want to make sure that that's
relevant the other thing we look at as
well is the wider policies we need
each of the organizations so poverty
strategy things like that to make sure
all of that is playing into our thinking
so we we understand
your organization better which
ultimately reflects what what
you know the people within trafford need
and want
from from procurement but also from the
council
you okay thank you can i just get you
need to say some more
or is it something maybe to feedback
after if it's a detail
um about how the waiting would work and
the way manchester is doing it perhaps
compared to other places
is there are there different options for
that i have asked peter scofield my
opposite number in manchester if you can
just share his methodology because i'd
love to see how they're doing it and
then what i will be doing is
recommending to a boarding joint
committee
an approach that i think is is
appropriate for our organizations but
it's definitely on the radar
and councillor russell shaw will be
feeding that back in once we've had that
discussion
tomorrow thank you very much that's
really helpful thank you
council boys is next then councillor
thompson yeah yeah a couple of questions
actually
the first one is on um just on obviously
uncontrollable spend
are you able to give us let's say for
the four
boroughs excluding the ccgs at the
moment
and overall percentage within gm
figure um and and
perhaps all equally for the ccgs i i
expect those to be different from the
point of view like the supply chains
to the ccgs will be significantly
different from those to the boroughs so
just obviously we've got uh whatever 74
percent
intrapreneurs is it is it comparable
across the
the boroughs overall and the other ones
a silly question is
is it in that column actually what are
the two asterisks for
uh against the two to two figures we've
got two asterisks
with no indication on the slides as to
what an asterisk
means it's it's in the 1920 new data for
controllable spend and spent nationally
is it right no problem i'll have a look
at the slide and just have a look what
that's referring to and apologies if
i've missed that off the bottom
just in terms of your first question
counselor and we actually report on on
star
to board and joint committee as a shared
service we actually
report on um the outputs the performance
based on star but what we're able to do
is to break that down into you know
traffic rochester and so on
so what i've presented tonight is
obviously the spend data for trafford
but of course we do have all of the data
for the four councils i can't give you
an opinion across greater manchester
because
i sadly only work for four of you and
but we do have that intelligence for the
clinical commissioning groups as well as
our two other partners
i meant that for the four yeah
what was the spending in gm on
controllable expenditure because
basically it's like it's 74 in trafford
you must have a figure for
rochdale and stop what my view and and
all of those will be public information
so collectively you'll be able to tell
us what the now but you'll be able to
tell us that
you've got them in my head although yeah
i can get that information circulated no
problem at all
thank you and the other question was the
asterix on the powerpoint so just bear
with me
why i just clicked into the slide on my
screen
they might they might just be
superfluous i can't think that they
yeah 189
million
i i am going to guess and just say
because this is
a data extract there's probably been um
some references internally
and to apologize i should have removed
the asterisks off that column i think
it's
it's what you could call it a legacy
legacy asterisk for
for no particular relevance for this
meeting i think
definitely it hasn't got any relevance
so i'll make sure i get my
admin sharpen next time
okay thank you very much lorraine thank
you thanks
chris is cousin thompson at younes thank
you
um i just want some clarification you
said
in your report 57 of contracts go to gm
organizations and 27 percent
of spend stays in gm i'm just
trying to work out why one is so high
and one is so low is it
because yeah it's two two completely
different things counselor um
okay if you imagine we put um 100
contracts through
the social value portfolio in that 12
month period because
firstly we only put contracts through
the portal above 25 000 pounds
in value so the spend for traffic that's
below 25 000 which is actually
many more contracts because obviously
the lower spend is is
like an 80 20 sort of split so basically
if those hundred contracts just use a
figure
that are above 25 000 pounds in value
57 of those 100 were awarded to greater
manchester businesses
so we're only looking at the spend first
of all and that's for
all the four councils not just trafford
so it's two completely different data
set but it's a really good question
and then the 27 percent any any figures
that are on the numbers charts within
the
powerpoint that's trafford data and
traffic spend
so that's all of your spend we split it
into controllable
and uncontrollable which basically means
contracted out
or money that you spend on staffing
social care that sort of thing where
it's
it's
internal payments foster care payments
we split it down because what we look at
is what can procurement influence
so we can only influence where you
contract with a third party
and that's where those percentages come
in in terms of
it's a really good question it's you
know it's not a silly one because you're
looking at the data and thinking how
does that join up but it is it's two
separate things completely
okay thank you thanks very much
are there any more uh questions i can't
see any more hands going up
a quick look with this oh thanks very
much well thanks for that lorraine it's
very interesting keep up the good work
and perhaps we'll see you again in
person and when all this
stuff is over and uh in a year 12 months
time perhaps you can come back and
update us with the work you've been
doing by then so thanks for that thanks
for taking the time
to come and see us thank you bye
you don't have to stay the rain
okay we're going to item six now which
is the audit completion letter
which i think uh karen you're going to
do aren't you current
from the mozart's we'll be doing that
yeah i am yes thank you
thank you chair um so this is really
just to provide members with the update
from where we got to you will recall
i think i hope that i came to your
november meeting
with a report that set out that we had a
small amount for relatively about
standing work to complete
on the audit um and i came back in
february and said i thought we were
almost there but
but not quite by february i'm pleased to
report now that we did in fact sign the
audit report
um giving the unqualified opinion on the
council's accounts on the 10th of march
um and we wrote to councillor brotherton
at that time just to confirm the
position and to let you know
where things were up to and a copy of
that letter is now provided here for
uh members of the committee to see i
think
i think there are just a couple of
things to draw your attention to really
and the main area that took the took the
time and was actually the main
challenging area in terms of the audit
was around the valuation of the
council's property plans and equipment
and investment properties and you will
see from the detail provided in the
letter
as part of our audit we tested a total
of 78
valuations to ensure that they were
correct and we found errors in 39 of
them
so that's quite a high error rate and
not what we would normally expect to see
they were both under valuations and
overvaluations and as a
consequence of that um the net position
was a
an immaterial um
amendment that would have been required
for the accounts but because these are
estimates and because it was immaterial
uh management choice not to make that
change we have made some
internal control recommendations around
the council's processes for valuations
and they are set out that set out in a
bit more detail in the letter
together with the council's response i
think it's probably worth me just
being very clear and saying that work
that we do know on property planting
equipment is of greater depth
and on bigger sample sizes than we used
to a few years ago
and as a result we have had difficulties
with the work
that's required and the evidence we need
to see now in a number of places
but in trafford probably um you know on
a more challenging scale than elsewhere
the valuer has been really helpful um in
trying to provide the information
the council is engaging in conversations
with them about how things will be done
differently in the future we had uh when
we reported to you in november some work
out standing on the pension liability
that's now completed and obviously was
fine
and we had work out standing on cash and
cash equivalents i think you may recall
that we mentioned that we were missing
still a bank confirmation letter and
that's now being received
so the only thing that's now outstanding
in terms of the final completion of the
2019-20 audit
is the what's known as the wga the whole
of government accounts return
and that's the bit where the council
needs to upload the details that are in
its accounts plus some other supporting
information
into a system operated by the treasury
we then
look at what's in there and make sure it
is consistent with the accounts and
supports the information
and then both parties sign it off and
you're not on your own in this piece of
work being still outstanding for
two reasons firstly we can't start it
until we finish the audit
and then the second reason is that the
oscar system as it is known is proving
particularly difficult to use
and there are an awful lot of technical
problems with it and we are
working with the council to get that
resolved as soon as possible
i expect we will get it signed off in
the next few days
that's all i was going to say really but
i am happy to take any questions
the reports the appendix to the report
just for clarity
uh includes all of the changes that have
been made to the council's accounts
including those that were reported to
you in november
just so that members could see the full
pit okay thanks karen any
questions or comments
no mark no nothing
quite happy with that are we
you muted sorry mark
um yeah in terms of um the internal
audit aspect
i've got some contact with the finance
team
uh on this and know that getting
insurance that there's a lot dialogue
between finance and amy
and regular meetings and i know as
improvement plan
referred to in that letter and they're
working on improvements around
providing the information and having
this appropriate support and information
um so hopefully you know we'll see
improvements for the the coming round
for the coming audit
um but it is potentially an area in
turnlord it could
they get involved in in the future you
know for the sort of ongoing issues with
it
okay thanks any all the comments
no well thank you sorry sorry chair i
just think from me i was just struggling
to find my hand
i think just from just from our uh
management control point of view i think
i think there's an element to taking
stock in that this is probably
the most difficult year both karen and
the team
and our team have had to close the
accounts down um
we have achieved it but obviously seeing
seeing the output from the ppe work and
the valuations has been slightly
disappointing
um we have been working really closely
with
um amy around the valuations
and in terms of the valuations for this
financial year's accounts
i had a meeting this afternoon that
reassured me that the process
and the checking of that process is now
incomplete at this stage so
i do feel at this stage we're in a far
far better position than what we were
um during the close down for 1920
um so that's just all i'd like to add to
you yeah
that's great coastal mitchell got your
hand up
muted thank you yes uh no i
i was just a little bit uh worried uh
about the um
property um errors
we've got a balance is overstated
of about two-thirds of a million
um what's been done to ensure that this
does not continue in the future
particularly when the council has been
uh
fairly um well castigated
uh for errors and
their mistakes of property
investments that was the question thank
you
thanks thanks
i'll answer that i think what we do is
when you look at
the assets that were undervalued i think
just looking at the list of assets
there's a couple of investment assets
there
um and when i talk about investment
assets these are
assets that we've owned as a council for
many
many years they're they were our old
commercial type property
um things around properties around herbs
and town centre
but they're quite minor in value i think
when you look at the spread of the
detail it is
it is mainly around schools um
respect of the assets that were
undervalued sorry that was the assets
that were overflowed in those that were
undervalued
there was one particular case and it's
it's the way the process work it was um
one of our school buildings one of our
largest school buildings that we still
have on our balance sheet at stratford
high school
and what had happened was the valuer had
inadvertently
missed a block from that valuation
process and that's been picked up on the
sample check now
this particular block had been missed
from the accounts for quite a number of
years so it wasn't the case that it was
just missed off this year and the asset
value significantly dropped it had been
it had been an historical adjustment
that had not been made so
the assets in question um
are really just the school assets with
some of our investment property but that
i would say is very very
small in scale um compared to the values
attached with some of the school
buildings which as you can imagine will
be quite large in value
but but i think what we've instigated
this time is the process of
we're doing 100 checks on every
calculation
just to double check uh the workings
from our values
[Music]
okay thanks little keller
yeah thank you and thank you graham
uh for your uh exploration thank you
thanks council lloyd is next well
yeah i would have declared an interest
if i've known you i'm going to speak
about threat for time
i'm a governor at stratford high and um
do i apologize on their behalf
thank you okay thanks for that
i can't see any any more hands up so
can i can i just make one more
observation on the back of it which is
that
um whilst it's frustrating for the
council that there were so many
um you know as graham said relatively
minor errors it's probably worth bearing
in mind that they weren't in respect of
um assets that largely weren't in
respective assets where the council
would be looking to borrow money on the
back of them or to make a further
investment in them
so these are assets that you carry
because they provide services
for the most part and i think it's
important to just bear in mind that this
is
a council and it is a slightly different
environment than the commercial world
where somebody might be wanting to make
decisions on the back of asset values
you're not quite in that place
okay thanks very much okay
great were you oh sorry no no it's all
right
because we go on to the next item then
which is item seven the annual
uh government statement which i think uh
as it was in the fall papers with the
today or at least
it was one supplementary agent item and
another supplementary item today
but alexander murray you're going to
deal with that i believe alex aren't you
uh yes i'm just gonna briefly thank you
chair
my name is alex murray i'm a governance
officer uh so yeah the annual governance
statement
um as is in the name is an annual
document that we prepare
that looks at the governance
arrangements of the council and
demonstrates
how the council meets the seven
principles of the governance
and the document uh sorry the report
that was uh circulated
uh covers the process that we go through
in order to complete the annual
government
governance statement each year and the
main differences this year is that um
the deadline
has been moved back uh by a month for
publishing the draft
so the draft is normally published in
june this year it will be july
and you will receive a copy of the draft
as the committee will receive a
copy of the draft before it's published
online
and then following it being published
online
external auditors have a chance to look
at it and their feedback will be taken
into account and then a final version
will be published in september again
the committee will see it before it is
published
um appendix one of the report is uh the
times
timeline for us to complete the
statement this year
and appendix ii is a document from
siffer which
was released earlier this year and
draws focus of the elements that they
expect to see within
the annual government statement this
year two of the
the two main factors that are different
to usual years are obviously the kobe 19
pandemic
and the other one is the financial
management code
which the year just gone was the shady
year of
so it's what we've been doing to prepare
to meet the code
in the coming year so yeah that's pretty
much
everything that they're coming to us to
note the process and know that they will
um be given a chance to look at both the
draft and the final version before
they're published
okay so you've got any questions thanks
any questions
i can't see any hands going up but as
you say we'll have a
further uh input to review the draft
version later on what way
yes you will we will have a chance for
the draft done the chance before the
final one goes
thanks very much can we agree then the
recommendations should denote the
timetable and
action plan and note that we'll have
input
revised in the draft version later on
can we all agree that
yeah thanks very much thank you
thank you thank you thanks alex for that
yeah
see him iso 8 is the audited insurance
service internal audit operation plan
which mark foster's going to take
thank you chad um so yeah this report
sets out
um our high level plans for an internal
audit for the year ahead
um it's a report that's been shared
with council's corporate leadership team
um we've had engagement from each of the
corporate directors
uh in putting together the plan we've
we've looked at
sort of researching good practice and
other authorities for ideas but also
importantly getting input from from
corporate directors and services into
the plan
um as i've previously reported to the
committee there's been
obvious disruption over the last 12
months um
to to to work our audit work um
and some work has been rescheduled and
we reflect that in the
2122 plan we've had discussions with
with each service area
around considering further work and and
any work that's been rescheduled
considering how we put it into this
year's plan
um and also what we didn't have this
time last year
we built in time to to continue to
provide support around the covid
uh response recovery um we've had a role
supporting other services in the grant
payments to businesses
and we'd expect that to continue uh to
some degree uh this year so
this time i have put some time aside for
it
um just in terms of the report as well
as the plan which i'll talk about a bit
more in a second
um there's also the audit charter and
strategy
uh in the appendices and this basically
is a document the charter sets out the
role of audit what we do
um and the strategy sets out in detail
how we how we operate and how how we
undertake our our audit work um
i've shared it with the committee this
time because we've made some very it's
already been
approved by the committee previously but
we've made some minor amendments to it
uh to reflect um the retirement of nicki
bishop
being section one up 151 officer and
graham bentley now becoming section 151
officer
so we've reflected that in in the
document so you'll see highlighted
sections there
where we've made those updates um but
just going back to the plan and the
planned work
um in terms of the report section three
uh starting on page 23 just summarizes
number of areas and factors we've taken
into account in putting the plan
together which has sat out in a bit more
detail
throughout the report um draw your
attention to
3.17 um that talks about resources
we have to to undertake the plan and
i've i've calculated their 1010
audit days to to complete the work
during the year
um and that's based on our resources in
terms of internal audit staff
both in-house and also um
resorts that we do purchase from outside
specialist help we get from salford who
work for a number of authorities across
the northwest with with it audit support
so in terms of the the days we've then
allocated those
out across a number of categories of
work
um section four of the report on page 26
just covers our reporting and
performance monitoring of the plan
and obviously an acknowledgement that
there'll be updates
throughout the year to the committee
and talk about progress and also if
there are any changes to the plan
uh any amendments and work added or
taken away etc
um and then the main body of the report
in section five
covers all the areas of planned work
um covered 19 impact it
it sort of runs through quite a lot of
the areas in terms of we'll consider
there been any changes in processes or
you know
taking into account that in in work we
do
also um so that that sort of a thread
that runs through a lot of the work
just to run through very briefly
each of the main categories um section
5.2 covers financial systems
and you'll see there's a there are a
number of reviews we have planned for
the year
around that um we'd also um
share our work with the external auditor
if there any areas we we
you know we need to discuss and uh any
issues to follow up on as a result of
external audit for instance
um so financial systems 5.3 governance
see very very relevant to the previous
item on the annual government statement
um audit works with legal and democratic
services around this and provide some
independent review
and support to the process in in
producing the statement uh
then moving to the next section 5.4 risk
management
which is another item on the agenda and
there's the ongoing role we have
in terms of reporting on risks and the
strategic risk register
but also in linked to that doing a
number of audit reviews
considering some of the strategic risks
so for instance in the plan
information governance is there which is
on the strategic risk register we'll be
doing a review of data breaches
follow-up process processes on that
there are a number of
audits around children's services and
adult services in terms of systems
there's an audit on health and safety
another on cyber security
that salford will be helping us on see a
number of financial system reviews so
trying to cover cover off a number of
the strategic risks as part of the plan
um anti-fraud work as well
um looking at internal controls to
reduce the risk of fraud
throughout the work um we also support
the national fraud initiative exercise
which looks at data matching across the
country um
so we'll continue having a role
coordinating that with other services
and we'll work carefully as well work
closely with david wright's team
we'll provide an update later in the
year on on the fraud work
in his team and we may if particular
pieces of work come up
uh include time to work with him
um there's procurement it's irrelevant
to the first item with lorraine
um we've worked with lorraine in terms
of uh
and also linking him with the other star
authorities
we've got a social value follow-up
review for instance uh
early on in the year uh following up on
a piece of work we did last year
uh on ict cyber security
a number of pieces of work around that
referred to in
5.8 5.7 sorry
and also information governance
were data breaches as i said will be
covered as part of that area of work
5.8 an area that has been affected to
some degree
uh in in the current year with
rescheduling work the schools
with again a number of schools planned
for the year
we have start resumed doing our school
audit work and there's been
there are a number of audits in progress
at the moment
so we'd hopefully continue the momentum
on that as we're going into the new year
and then 5.9 other business risks which
really captures a number of areas across
the council different services different
functions
you can see there are audits within the
place of children's
adults etc
just finally the last couple of sections
5.10 data quality and grant claims
that's some ongoing work of grant claims
we we
tend to have a role in certifying so for
instance a disabled facilities grant
um but i think this year as well the
code with 19 grants will obviously be a
be a major part of our work in different
ways and having different roles
supporting different services around
that
and then general service advice project
support they're issues that crop up
through the year
and would make some time in the plan we
may attend for instance system board
meetings from
adult services children services etc
um and then just in terms of the plan as
a whole
there's a number of reviews around
follow-ups so looking at work we've done
this year and
looking at progress and implementing
recommendations and of course we report
regularly
to the committee on progress in
implementing previous recommendations
um a small amount of contingency will
put in the plan
see plans as we found out this year
certainly subject to change
and there's some time in there to deal
with unexpected events or reduced
resources
um but keeping the plan flexible i think
it's a crucial thing and that's
something we'll
update the committee on through the year
as as as circumstances
occur through the year just
in terms of the the audits and listings
of them
you'll see an appendix one um
page 37 uh the categories of audit work
and
a summary there in terms of planned time
against each of those
and then in the in the appendix 2
there's a list of areas where we'd
expect to
produce audit reports and provide an
audit opinion on
um in terms of this listing it will be
a combination of issuing the reports
through the year ahead
or starting the reviews and issuing
reports in the year after
he said i'll put an asterisk there in
terms of
denoting where we'd expect reports to be
issued in the first
quarter of the year
and then just just to draw members
attention as well
on page 43 to audit opinion levels
um a lot of you will be familiar with
our opinions
in terms of they range from low to high
and there are five opinion levels we're
looking at
the best practice that's come out this
year from siffer
um we're basically now aligned to that
best practice so we're now going to work
to four opinion levels
um you'll see in the table the the top
one being substantial assurance
uh very low or no assurance which would
be obvious an area of concern
and so we'll be looking at all reports
that are
issued from april uh we'll we'll be
using those opinion levels
um so finally just just to say as well
to report on progress work in this plan
and over the course of the year so we'll
include it in the work program
uh regular updates thanks chair
thanks mark any questions about that
i can't see any hands going up can i
just ask
a simple quote you mentioned the four
levels of um
the top two levels are still going to be
greener
it doesn't matter really but yes um at
the moment with the five levels we have
the top three are green
all right uh the fourth is amber and the
fifth is red
um so it's really i don't think it's
gonna affect so much obviously either
very good or a very poor review
yeah the top or bottom one i think the
challenge will be in the middle ones
and where opinions uh sit
um so you know
ones that were medium before could could
go potentially to the second one
reasonable or the third one limited
yeah i think it's just a restructuring
of our our level so we've got
with the guidance we've given to
auditors supporting that as well to help
them
you know when when they're producing an
opinion level yeah
okay so so it's only the borderline ones
could either be in the
the little green band or for example or
top of the red bandage
yes a borderline one it could
potentially now
that might have been a green and a
medium could potentially become an amber
being limited um because only having
four levels
yeah there's no middle ground in that
respect um
so i think it's i mean something we've
communicated to clt that
just to understand that any the change
there
um a lot of there's been a lot of
inconsistency across the country
with numbers of opinion levels across
audit sections i think it's it for a
very useful really producing these
guidance so
i would expect now most would use
this new this new arrangement okay
thanks for that
i can't say any other questions so can
we go on to adam uh
nine the strategic risk register updates
again it's you mark
thank you um yeah so we've we've uh
recently uh coordinated an update
register
liaison with with clt um so we've
obtained updates through sort of from
the end of february
um through march um
so you'll see from the report there's
still 16 um
strategic risks listed
um but have been some changes since we
are last reported in november
on this um these are referred to
in section 2.3
of the report
there are a couple of risks where the
risk scores
gone down one risk 16
relation to the university academy 92
has gone from a still a medium risk but
gone down in score from 15 to nine
so there's an update in the report that
reflects that
uh and risk nine identifying
safeguarding vulnerable children has
gone from
20 to a medium of 15.
um i think that really reflects sort of
progress
in recent months and the recent ofsted
follow-up visit and so again there's
reference to that
in the report um 2.4 just to
to pick up on an error here for another
risk risk nine it should actually say
risk
eight um and that was the brexit
risk impact of brexit it's actually been
widened now
to consider us very importantly with the
impact of cobit 19
so the risk description there in the
report
that reflects that widening uh of the
risk
so details of each of those 16 risks are
in the
section three uh of the report and
you know we'll continue obviously to
scheduling further updates to the
committee and if there are particular
areas the committee is interested in
receiving further information on that
could potentially be
considered for the program for the next
year
yeah okay any comments or anybody
questions or comments
i can't see any hands going up so thanks
for that sorry yeah i saw each other i'm
just trying i'll mute myself there oh
sorry because i have a picture as well
sorry yeah just on
is this on a couple of questions really
around
the risk about uh data and it's two
things
one is um on subject
access requests how
what are they in terms as opposed to
freedom of information requests as far
as the council is concerned is this
information that the council holds about
an individual in the same way
you get a subject access request to a
hospital or your gp
or something like that that's the first
question and the other question is on
the matter of
data commercially sensitive et cetera et
cetera et cetera and third parties
can you comment and assure us that the
whole aspect of whatever's been going on
at
amy with its server actually hasn't
impacted or impinged upon
us as a council thank you
yes um
dominique sykes has come in the past to
this uh committee giving
an update around the uh the information
governance side and
subject access requests yeah
understanding for the individual
somebody actually wanting
uh information specifically uh you know
about themselves
that the council holds uh whereas
foreign
um and i know both areas um
we've talked about both of these areas
there's also possible inclusions for the
audit climate we've got the data
breaches one in
first we recognize that there's work
going on in the council
it's referred to in this report in terms
of developments and progressing
and trying to reduce the the backlog
um so i know it's an ongoing piece of
work
whether it's something potentially with
the committee we could get some more
detailed
update on it some stage in terms of how
those improvements are going and how
they translate into
uh results in terms of reductions in
backlogs
so that's in terms of in terms of that
side of things
um with with the amy i know um
from speaking to um the chief digital
officer
my understanding was at that stage there
wasn't an issue specifically for the
council
um i haven't got like a completely
up-to-date
view on that but my understanding i'm
not sure whether whether graham would
would have any further information but i
i wasn't aware of any
any issues at this stage come in and
come back to grandma look the reason i'm
raising it because it just seems to be
going on and on and on a very very long
time
that's sort of that's what's concerning
me about the amy situation
and there's all sorts of things that
they're saying that they can't do that
they can't
access uh although it would seem
obviously that the
uh the portal for reporting
you know my traffic whatever like i put
loads of loads of things on about
various things that that seems to be
operating quite
reasonably well so uh through whatever
channel that goes but as i say
it is the fact that uh that the amy
the amy server issues seem to be more
complicated than they thought to begin
with they've gone on
a long time so i think yeah graham
yeah just to add from what mark said i'm
not
i'm not wholly sure on what paul's
latest updates are from
from amy i i think it's something we can
feedback separately
to your counselor boys right okay thank
you very much thank you thank you chair
thank you i can't see anymore
hands going up no so thanks to that mark
next item is the uh
stuff the budget monitoring which is
graham i think
yeah i'll take that chair thank you um
yeah
included in this report uh this is just
what was taken to our executive
uh meeting yesterday um reporting on our
out-term position as at period 10. so
we're very close to our turn
um i think in terms of this year's
reporting of our financial position
um it has been difficult
um purely because of the impact that
clovid's had across the range of budgets
we've had
we've got just just within the report
i'll just maybe start on the core with
issues and then come back to the summary
of the report
which um we've provided an exact summary
which hopefully
brings out the key points within the
rest of the report
but just on page number
83 of the pack you'll see a table there
it's just probably worth understanding
what the impact to kovid has had
on the authorities finances this this
financial year
um what the what table four
does show is that the the gross the
gross impact
of of covert across our expenditure
across our income streams and across
our council tax receipts and business
rate receipts
as an impact to just short of 57 million
pounds
what what we've also detailed there is
obviously through the various reporting
that we've done and through the various
packages of support we've received
both from government and from the ccg
um we're left with what what i'm calling
a net covered pressure about three
quarters the way down the table of just
short of 14 million
so i would say that's probably the
unfunded costs this financial year
um that we've been left with now what
governments have also
done exceptionally this year is in
respect of
uh the deficits around council tax
collection and some business rates
income
they've allowed us to um
repay those deficits over the following
three years
so taking all that into account this
there's an overall impact to just over
five million pounds from covered this
year
um what's probably just interesting to
note there is that
um whilst governments have tried to
cover our costs they've been quite
open in saying we're not going to cover
losses from commercial property and
if you think in terms of the council's
budget
we do budget for income from the airport
um we do get a dividend from the airport
which we were budgeting at about five
and we're getting about five million
pound
we're not getting that and we've not got
that in 2021 and we don't expect to get
that for
another couple of years so that really
is is one of the key unfunded issues of
corvid and
if you think about a district like
manchester who's got a bigger
shareholding than trafford
these are massive numbers
so just in terms of the rest of the
report and if i can just go
back to the summary um at the start of
the report
what we what we've got is whilst that
whilst covert has impacted on our budget
uh as i've just discussed there are
other other aspects of the budget that
have
have seen benefits um and when we when
we take the two
into consideration and consolidate them
we're projecting and underspend on our
budget
overall of 2.3 million um
slightly better than what we were
projecting at period eight which was a
figure of 2.1 million under spend
um what will happen at year end is
if that balance and if that underspend
is actually realized that we'll move
into our budget support reserve to
support future years budgets
just another couple of points from the
summary
around council tax and reserves um
our council tax collection this year has
been affected
um but what we've seen throughout the
year is that
it's been an improving position so we're
still not collecting
quite what we would expect in a normal
year
um we're about two percent collection
down compared to normal um
at the start of the year i think we're
all looking at thinking that might be
more like five percent
that was what other authorities were
estimating as well
um just in terms of a couple of reserve
movements this time we have been able to
put some amounts into reserves
um these were expected particularly
around some redistributions from the
combined authority
um and just to finish off there there's
just a comment around the capital
programme and some minor rephasing
um on that but we're still leaving a
projected capital
expenditure of about 37 million pounds
this year so
happy to take any questions chair thanks
graeme any questions
geraldine thank you thank you
and thanks graham and and everyone for
that
um i just wanted to pick up on them what
graeme was mentioning about the airport
and say
yeah i mean something i've raised in
other forums before that you know as
long as
our long-term plan is to remain
financially dependent on the airport for
a large amount of money and for
something like 2019 levels of travel
that's not compatible with our climate
neutral
ambitions so there is um there is a
tension there
and you know i i just keep need feel the
need to keep
flagging up to people that we cannot
actually continue to assume we will be
getting that level of funding in
thanks thanks
just to add to that thanks uh councillor
coggins i think it's fair to say that
the dividends that we'd got pre-pandemic
had
lifted up from
i don't know what they were a few years
ago but they'd reached about five
million pounds for each district
manchester were getting substantially
more than that because of the the size
of their shareholding
um i think it's fair to say within the
budget plans we've got that
we are expecting dividends to return at
a point in the medium
term but but not at the levels that
we've come down from
um to use that analogy uh that we've
come down from pre-2020-21
yep remember i think years ago
you were talking about the 350 thousand
half a million that's what the level
and it's just it's just ramped up over
the over the years yes
um about the money that's come back on
the growth pilot
scheme is that a one-off or is that
something that would
happen again in the future it's
it's a one-off redistribution is that
what what we've done in the last few
years because we've had
what we call a business rate growth
pilot and within greater manchester
we've been able to retain
some elements of growth from our
business rates
the combined authority has benefited
from that as well
and as part of the corvid work and the
response to corvid
and helping out districts the priorities
that
greater manchester had for the use of
their share of these buddies have been
reviewed
and that's led to this release so it's
been a one-off release really to help us
out around the call with issues that
we've been facing
thank you council evans next and then
councillor thompson
councillor boys thank you chair just
referring back to the airport obviously
we're short of dividend which is obvious
is there any inkling that
um they might be requiring any further
injection of capital at all
i think just on that i think the
agreement that we got at council
um was for a package of support
in two tranches i know we've paid the
first tranche i think overall it was
about
just over 12 million per district um
we've paid i think just short of 10 with
a further distribution to make
now that's not been called for us as i'm
aware of
at this stage it's still a budgeted item
um but i've not heard uh whether or not
that will be required this financial
year or not
so are we we're doing that at a cash
flow our cash or are we borrowing that
and so
got a 10 and we've got another two
tomorrow in you know
if they ask for it or are we doing our
general day-to-day
it's it's borrowing i think what what
we've got there is that
obviously the rates we can borrow are
quite low um
and we are actually charging there's a
commercial interest rate
attached with that so it does actually
give us some net income to the budget
does that facility so we are borrowing
for that
is that okay all right
councillor thompson is next thank you
i think i already know the answer to
this but are we expecting
any more support from government to
cover our
covered costs or any support from from
other places that we might
be bringing in going forward in the next
maybe one or two years
that's a good question i think there was
a report produced by the national audit
office
in the last couple of weeks that
basically identified
a couple of things it identified the
pressures authorities had faced
in 2021 and i think it's the
the figures you broadly talking about in
expenditure in income terms
is about 10 billion pounds across all
authorities
at the moment i think the government
funding packages in total or it becomes
about 9 billion
slight shortfall there but then what
they've also
done government they recognize the fact
that covered pressures will
will continue now when the budgets were
set
they were set based on the information
we knew from the spending round last
year and the financial settlement we got
at christmas so what they were saying at
that stage and it
is pre the lockdown that we've had since
christmas
was that we thought they thought
pressures would continue for at least
the first quarter
now and and and funding was provided
and has been provided now what we're
seeing is the likelihood is they will
continue well beyond that
so i think there's a fair chance that
there could be a reaction from
government and that further funding will
come
i think one of the other aspects that
we've just seen
um in the last week is that
the issue around delayed discharges and
making sure we can
find care accommodation for people who
need to leave hospital
quickly to create the capacity within
the hospitals
i think what we were concerned about was
that throughout the year we've had a lot
of funding from the ccg
the clinical commissioning group that
they've got from nhs england
to support councils in in making sure
they've got enough places
and what we've just heard is that some
of that support will continue again
in 2122 and i think a lot of it will be
around
obviously there's a backlog of of um
hospital treatments that need doing so
there'll be that requirement to keep
the capacity within the acute sector is
as good as possible so
it's it's it's good news that we've
actually got notification of additional
funding for that as well
okay is that okay thanks
counselor boys next yeah thank you
chairman yeah a couple of things two
different talking one just going back to
the airport i mean
the i mean the situation there's and i
mean i'm on the probably
one of the committees there as other
councillors are but
the last i heard that the airport was
actually with the group which includes
stansted
was actually losing 25 million pounds a
month
and i don't think it's probably improved
very much since then so in terms of the
dividends
i think it's going to be a little bit
longer than even we're talking tonight
about it
but i'd also say that at the moment of
course like the vast majority of flights
that are taking place
are actually commercial goods flights
and and without those
i think the threat to the economic
prosperity of gm
will be significant and and let's face
it the airport is key
to the future economic prosperity of the
area
the other thing just going back to the
whole business of budgets and figures
and numbers i've been trying to
get my head around budget monitoring and
what have you for the last nine years
now graham
um but so but basically what we're
saying really is that
after all is said and done uh
notwithstanding there is a sort of five
million pounds plus
roundabout figure short because of the
airport situation
allowing for the deferment of the
council tax
and business tax what have you the the
40 million pound hole blown in our
budget
doesn't actually exist thank you
i think i think just through the
reaction to that i think for the current
year that is the suggestion that we've
got a 40 million pound poll
blown in it by central government is is
untrue
i think just to react to that i said
thanks for your question i think
what we've seen throughout the year is
the numbers have developed and i think
what we've been having on that position
at the start
yeah it wouldn't have been that but i
think what
what we've done and what government's
done and i think to some extent
mhclg have worked with authorities
really productively i think and
obviously
through the monitoring that authorities
have done and dave will
agree here that we've done monthly
monitoring every district has done
and the spreadsheet that goes back to
clg each month
with all the data on spend it's quite a
mammoth thing so
300 authorities the government are
getting that back clg is getting that
back chelated that are going to treasury
so
what we've seen is this is the issue and
we've seen it
we've seen that positive reaction
in terms of the funding that's that's
come come forward to date
the corvette funding is still 15 14
million
short is it i think when you look at
when you look at the
the cash side of things it's about 40
million pound
adrift but then governments then
exceptionally allowed us
some of that 40 million to do with
deficits on our council tax collection
and business rates collection
so they basically said you pay those
back over the next three years
this is a three-year period yeah yeah
yeah
so it's not a diff it's not a deferment
indefinitely it's actually a
it's a postponement it's it's as we know
it's like
you know as you just said graham i mean
this is i mean this is like one
authority out
of whatever is 200 300 authorities it's
an absolute mammoth task
and i mean i i will use the word only
once as they said
you know they can't like you know it's
absolutely
unprecedented uh arisings and and
times that we've lived in during the
last 12 months obviously
in my lifetime in barry's lifetime
there's nothing ever like this has ever
come along
so you know
just hopefully we'll we'll get through
it like the queen said
uh in her broadcast back in it seems
only yesterday but it was back in about
may wasn't
it so yeah thank you very much i have
my lifetime so maybe this is the second
most important yeah but i mean i don't
know well yes um i think it was your
mother and father was sort of sorting
you out though wasn't it
i remember okay
thanks for that i can't see anybody
else's uh hands going up
so we come on to uh uh mr mugbridge now
accounting concepts and policies
dave mcgritch i saw his name on the list
somewhere yeah i'm here can you admire
you hear me here dave yeah right okay
thank you
um right this uh report that we
i think this is the third year that we
brought this this report is
this this is the accounting policies
approval for counting policies which are
basically the rules
and the concepts that we apply and
producing the statutory accounts
and there's no obligation under the
accounting code to bring these it's just
a
really best practice and also to raise
some of the principles which we intend
to use
to your attention um i think we will
cover these as part of the training
training program as well when we do the
final accounts
um we're also required to highlight in
in
the in in the account so they're in the
reports the accounting standards have
been issued
but not yet adopted so this is the next
financial year on
so you obviously have an understanding
of what the consequences of
of those are in the current uh financial
year
um so basically uh the report the
detailed
policies we are going to apply covered
in appendix one to the report there's a
lot of them
uh some of them are very technical uh
some of them are very general
and appendix 2 this shoot issue
identifies those
that have been uh have been issued and
the changes from last year
which thankfully they're only mainly
points of technical clarity
they're either not relevant to the to
the council or due to miserination we
don't require to update our policies for
those
um so just in terms of the uh some of
the general
principles uh covered under the um
under the council policies the big the
biggest one of the general principles is
the requirement to actually apply the
accounting code of practice
um issued by cipra which also mirrors
international
financial reporting standards and one of
the other
core principles is the going concern so
it
mainly applies to private sector
companies
when you prepare your accounts at the
end when the financial year
you have to look a forward 12 months and
say are you going to continue to trade
and it's not generally an issue for for
local government obviously because
uh we are supported through any uh
support if we were looking
to go into a state of insolvency the
government would step in
um but we do have to demonstrate that we
will carry on as a going concern over
the next 12 months
and the this is an indication that the
auditors will be looking at that because
of the implications of covid
uh to make sure that we have actually
assessed that
um and things that they've been looking
at there in terms of our
levels of reserves uh the budget
monitoring we do throughout the year
issues as sustainability being
considered and issues for instance in
the strategic risk register
so that's an area that's going to be
focused on across
across the country and as i said the the
counter account there's a lot of detail
in the
in the accounting policies uh some of
the key ones
are mentioned in in in the introduction
to the report
um just to mention a few of them which
um they can't the accruals and income
is is a key policy basically we have to
account for
um the income and expenditure that's
been occurred that's not necessarily
being paid
so for instance if we if we have an
invoice outstanding we have to charge
that expenditure in
in the current financial year and hold
ours as a liability on the balance sheet
and cover the things that are accounting
uh for non-current assets
how we treat our assets on the balance
sheet how we depreciate those
um for instance this is one of the
policies that says any vehicle
planning equipment that's got used for
life between eight and
uh three years we'll actually depreciate
that and charge that use of that asset
over a straight line basis over the life
of that asset
and these things in there for instance
schools how we treat
the schools balances uh community and
foundation schools for instance they're
owned by the council
so they appear on our balance sheet four
and traded schools and control schools
are owned by the respective diocese so
that we actually
uh we don't know those so they're not on
our balance sheet
and so as i said the the full details
are included in appendix one um
the um the next part of the section is
looking at
policies issued not adult not yet
adopted
um there's no significant changes the
only one in the pipeline is that is how
we're going to treat
at lease leases um it was supposed to be
implemented this year
because of the covid uh pandemic they
actually stalled it for 12 months so
it's coming in
um in the next financial year and
so basically the way the uh this is
covered by a
standard called ifrs16 um
it it came about i think there was one
of the directors who won the airline sat
on the plane
on the runway and they were renting that
plane
off of a third party
and they realized that that asset didn't
appear on their balance sheet even
though they had rights to use it
so there was quite a big exercise
undertaken to say there's a lot of
assets out there
the companies are using either for
leasing arrangements that aren't
actually appearing on the balance sheet
so what they've done is they reviewed
how how we actually treat those
so it's basically the two types of lease
there's a finance lease
where you actually pay
the right to use that asset over a
period of time then you eventually own
that asset once you've paid that the
loan off of the financing of that
and there's an operating lease where you
would have a rental agreement to make
right to use the sp don't actually own
the asset
so the counter standards look to that
answer well we want to bring those
together and treat those basically the
same
so there's no differentiation between
finance leases and operating leases
so so they've actually said right if you
have a right
you're doing an operating lease where
you're paying a rental
we need to say you've got to bring that
on as
an asset on your balance sheet so you
are right you're you're showing that i
said on you on your balance sheet
you would you you'd use that any
depreciation and charge for the use of
that asset
uh as you would do um if you physically
owned it
so that that that's a significant change
that's coming in
um we we're still reviewing the impact
of it um we're not expecting it to have
any any significant issue but for
instance if there's any contracts where
there's an embedded um
um right an asset with it embedded
within that that's unique for us to
to use it nobody else has our rights in
that asset uh for instance as a
residential
accommodation we have all the beds in
there potentially that's the thing that
might have to appear on our balance
sheet
so we might we might see changes in the
value of the assets that do come on our
balance sheet
as i say we still understand the impact
of of that side of things
so we should have a better idea um over
the course of uh for the next financial
year
and so that's the biggest change after
the uh
thing the the changes so far
so i suppose that's and that seems to
the recommendation is to
approve the the current uh
suggestion for the accounting policies
and appendix one and to know the changes
in
pipeline thanks dave
any questions on comments
i can't see any any hands going up so
can we just agree the recommendations at
the front of the report
okay thank you
thank go you to the agenda
well the next item is the work program
which i think is uh
mark again yeah so it just sets out
the program that we've undertaken
through the year
um so the main areas
were covered um i think before the
committee meets again there's just
there'll be one further report
circulated outside of the meeting that
would be the
uh external audit strategy memorandum
which was
set up planned work for the for the
audit the 2021 account so that that'll
be circulated to members before
before they meet again um
produce an annual report for the year as
we always do
so that i expect that to be ready uh by
the time we
meet again and also um
work plan for the for the coming year um
will be agreed at the
the next committee meeting
thanks any questions or comments on the
work plan
i can't say the hands going up okay well
thanks for that mark
so we come to itunes 13 which is uh
urgent business and not been
informed of any urgent business i'm not
aware of any
no okay well that's the end of the
meeting it's actually the last
meeting i've only just realized that at
the present municipal year
so uh some of us uh i can see a few
faces
on here including myself who are up for
election this year so
let's hope uh we meet again perhaps in
in body rather than on virtually in the
in the uh in the new municipal year not
new year so thanks everybody i'll see
you hopefully
next year sent barry a message
separately he's thanking him for his
chairmanship
during the year and i'm sure he'll agree
he does a very good job of it
virtually with that fantastic bookcase
behind him
the big case
thank you very much barry and
thank you for the the team this year
they've done a damn good job
yeah thank you i'll see you all bye